Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge”（循环收入竞赛）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a memory and a trend is having the ability to help you learn about new and different ways that you can gain experience
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。在没有记忆和趋势的情况下，拥有能够帮助你学习获得心理学经验的新方法和不同方法的能力，
or even gain formal qualifications in psychology. So that is exactly what we are doing in today's episode. And this is a method I'd never heard of before. So with that little bit of intrigue, I will leave you now and you will then be introduced to my guest and I will catch you on the other side. Hope you find this so useful. Hi, welcome along. And I just want to welcome and introduce our guest for today. And we are joined by Aniga Sharma. Hi Anaga. Hi Marianne, it's really lovely to be here today. It's so lovely to have you here and I again accosted you on LinkedIn so you'd connected with me I think after you'd read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and then you were like yeah I am going to connect with her, she seems all right. And then I spotted recently that you are something
甚至获得心理学正式资格。这正是我们今天这期节目要做的。这是一种我以前从未听说过的方法。带着这点好奇心，我现在就把时间留给你，接下来你将见到我的嘉宾，我们稍后再见。希望你觉得这期节目很有用。嗨，欢迎收听。我想欢迎并介绍我们今天的嘉宾。我们邀请到了Anaga Sharma。你好，Anaga。你好，Marianne，很高兴今天能来到这里。很高兴你能来。我是在LinkedIn上“纠缠”你的，我想是在你读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书之后，你联系了我，当时你心想：“好吧，我要联系她，她看起来还不错。”后来我最近发现你正在做一件
that I'd never heard of. And so I messaged you for more information. You are a trainee, clinical and trainee forensic psychologist at the same time, aren't you? Yes, that's correct. Love it. Could you tell us a little bit more about how that works and how you got into it and what your journey was before you became a trainee? Quite a big question that one. That's a big question. Yeah, sure. So I'm currently a second year trainee forensic and clinical psychologist. And I'm on the University of Birmingham forensic clinical psychology doctorate. So it was kind of one of the first I think the only one in the UK at the moment I might be wrong with that the first combined doctorate where you can train
我从未听说过的事情。所以我发消息向你询问更多信息。你同时是一名临床心理学实习生和法医心理学实习生，对吧？是的，没错。太棒了。你能告诉我们更多关于这是如何运作的，你是如何进入这个领域的，以及在你成为实习生之前的经历吗？这是一个很大的问题。确实是个大问题。好的，没问题。我目前是法医和临床心理学专业的二年级实习生。我就读于伯明翰大学的法医临床心理学博士课程。我想这在英国目前是首个，也可能是唯一一个结合了法医和临床心理学培训的博士课程。这是一个为期四年的课程，本质上结合了伯明翰大学临床心理学博士课程和法医心理学博士课程的要素。通常情况下，如果你想同时获得法医和临床心理学家的双重资格，你必须先后完成两个博士学位，
to become a forensic and a clinical psychologist so it's a four-year course and essentially it combines elements from the clinical psychology doctorate that's run at Birmingham and the forensic psychology doctorate so in a way typically that if you wanted to become dual qualified as both a forensic and clinical psychologist you would have to go and do both doctorates separately kind of one after each other so you do maybe clinical training first then forensic or vice versa but the course was developed in a way that instead of doing two doctorates which then would mean probably about six years at least it kind of cuts and cuts and gets rid of anything that overlaps so I wouldn't have to do the same teaching again when I'm doing the kind of more forensic teaching if I've had it already in the
比如先完成临床培训，再完成法医培训，或者反之亦然。但这个课程的开发方式是，它不再需要攻读两个博士学位（那至少需要六年时间），而是删减并去除了所有重叠的部分。这样，如果我已经学习过临床要素中的相关内容，在进行法医教学时就不必重复学习同样的课程。
clinical elements so in that sense the first two years of the course are aligned with the clinical psychology doctorate at the university so I have kind of clinical teaching and then the last two years are with the forensic doctorate so we joined their cohort and have the forensic teaching. Sounds amazing and do you still have to do a thesis as part of that? Yes so that still includes a thesis but you'll just be doing one and I guess you start kind of collecting ideas for that in the first year and And then the second, third and fourth years are kind of where that kind of goes ahead. And then you submit it in your fourth year. So I guess compared to clinical trainees, you have an extra year then to do your thesis and the write up.
从这个意义上说，课程的前两年与大学的临床心理学博士课程保持一致，所以我会有临床教学，而最后两年则与法医博士课程对接，我们加入他们的队列并接受法医教学。听起来太棒了，那作为课程的一部分，你还需要写论文吗？是的，仍然需要论文，但你只需要写一篇。我想你从第一年就开始收集想法，然后在第二、三、四年进行深入研究，最后在第四年提交。所以相比临床实习生，你有一年的额外时间来完成论文和撰写工作。
Yeah. So it's four years and you come out with both and then you can register with the HCPC and the BPS as both. Yeah, that's right. Oh, love that. time efficiency as well because he wanted to study for six years if you can do it for four really really good really I really admire people who've done both because I think it's it's very long and I think it's a lot of hard work but being able to do it in a shorter route and still have the same benefits I think is really important and I understand understand from our little pre-chat that even within your cohort perhaps some of you are funded and some of you
是的。所以这是四年制的课程，毕业后你将同时获得两个资格，并可以在HCPC和BPS注册为双重身份。是的，没错。太棒了。这效率很高，因为如果能用四年完成，谁想花六年时间呢？真的非常好。我非常钦佩那些完成了双重学位的人，因为我认为这非常漫长，而且需要付出很多努力。但能够通过更短的途径获得同样的益处，我认为非常重要。我从我们之前的简短交流中了解到，即使在你们的队列中，有些人是有资助的，而有些人是
are self-funded so there's kind of a disparity even within the cohort. Yeah so the course started running in 2013 and they typically take five or six trainees kind of per cohort so I'm self-funded but there are some trainees who are also funded so there isn't like as far as I'm aware there isn't like specific places that are just self-funded or just funded so I guess from my experience of self-funding that means that you'd have to pay the university tuition fee as you would for like an undergraduate um degree and you pay a certain amount per annum I started in 2021 and my fee per year is 13 and a half thousand pounds which is a lot of money you can definitely appreciate that um and I think that fee kind of changes every year which is probably based on inflation I'm not sure exactly what um and I guess with self-funded that means
自费的，所以即使在同一个队列中也存在差异。是的，该课程从2013年开始开设，每届通常招收五到六名实习生。我是自费的，但也有一些实习生是有资助的。据我所知，并没有专门的“自费名额”或“资助名额”。以我的自费经验来看，这意味着你必须像本科生一样支付大学学费，每年支付一定金额。我于2021年开始学习，每年的学费是13500英镑，这是一笔不小的数目，你肯定能理解。而且我认为这个费用每年都会变动，可能是基于通货膨胀，我不确定具体原因。对于自费生来说，这意味着
when you do have your placement you're on an honorary contract so you won't necessarily get a paid placement I know that there are some paid placements out there I'm not sure how easy they are to find um and I guess that that could be difficult but so far my my placements have been more honorary contracts but there are some people on on the course who are funded and I know the university does have links with the Birmingham Solihull NHS Trust and with St Andrews Healthcare, and they're a private healthcare company. I'm not entirely sure how the funding works, but I guess it would be kind of speaking with the course
当你进行实习时，你签订的是荣誉合同，所以实习不一定是有薪水的。我知道外面有一些带薪实习，但不确定是否容易找到。这可能会比较困难，但到目前为止，我的实习大多是荣誉合同。不过课程中确实有一些人是有资助的，我知道大学与伯明翰索利哈尔NHS信托基金（Birmingham Solihull NHS Trust）以及圣安德鲁斯医疗保健公司（St Andrews Healthcare，一家私营医疗公司）有联系。我不完全确定资助是如何运作的，但我猜这需要与课程方
and speaking with kind of line management to sort that out. Yeah. So are you eligible to apply for like student loans funding to help or does it all have to be literally out your own pocket? Yeah so eligible to apply so I've applied for the postgraduate doctoral loan which is held by the government and it kind of works in a similar way as you would for like an undergraduate tuition fee so you apply for the loan. I think the amount that you can get is around 27 000 it might be a bit more than that I think that regularly changes um and I guess you can do whatever you want with that kind of funding that you get and you get it as you would in increments
以及直线管理部门沟通来解决。是的。那么你有资格申请学生贷款来帮助支付学费吗？还是必须完全自掏腰包？是的，我有资格申请。我申请了政府提供的研究生博士贷款，它的运作方式与本科生学费贷款类似。你可以申请贷款，我想金额大约是27000英镑，可能更多一点，这个数额经常变动。你可以随意使用这笔资金，它会分期发放，
so at three or four points in the year you get that kind of money um and then you're responsible with doing with kind of whatever you want with that um but it doesn't cover the entire tuition fee that's the only thing okay so are you having to kind of get paid employment to cover your living fees then as well um so I I think some people probably would try and do that I think I'm quite lucky because I've been financially in a position where I could self-fund but I appreciate that's not the case for a lot of people and the fees are really really high and we're not we don't really get the traditional like health like HEE funding that the clinical trainees would get and it's kind of a bit more similar to the forensic in that sense whereas because of forensic trainees tend to self-fund and don't have that
一年分三到四次发放。你可以自由支配这笔钱，但它不能覆盖全部学费，这是唯一的问题。好的，那你是否需要通过兼职工作来支付生活费？我想有些人可能会尝试这样做。我很幸运，因为我的经济状况允许我自费，但我理解很多人并非如此，而且学费确实非常高。我们并没有获得临床实习生那种传统的HEE（健康教育英格兰）资助。从这个意义上说，它更类似于法医心理学，因为法医实习生通常是自费的，没有来自政府或NHS的
allocated funding from the government or the NHS. Yeah there's definitely a difference isn't there so I remember when I was an assistant psychologist actually it's an Andrews Healthcare and yes the forensic trainees were self-funding whereas the clinical ones weren't and it's just difficult because essentially you're doing a very similar job and I think even some of the teaching that you're doing is pretty similar are you going to the clinical teaching or is it like separate for just you six on your cohort so we join um the other cohort teaching others I think it'd be very small for just the six of us um to have our teaching so in the first two years we join teaching on the
专项资助。是的，这确实有区别。我记得我还是助理心理学家时，在圣安德鲁斯医疗保健公司工作，那里的法医实习生确实是自费的，而临床实习生则不是。这很困难，因为本质上你们做的工作非常相似，而且我认为你们学习的一些课程也相当相似。你们是去参加临床教学，还是你们这六个人单独上课？我们加入其他队列的教学。我想如果我们六个人单独上课，规模会非常小。所以在前两年，我们加入
clinical course so we have all basically exclusively clinical teaching and then in the last two years the third and fourth years we join the forensic cohort and we have more of the forensic based teaching then but our placements across the kind of four years can be kind of exclusively clinical so maybe in more kind of clinical NHS mental health settings community or inpatient but they can also be in forensic settings so forensic mental health services and prison or probation services as well. I just think it sounds brilliant like you must I don't know just that depth of knowledge and experience that you're able to be acquiring is really good so when I was an assistant I was in forensic services all of my assistant posts were forensic services and I really liked the yeah that knowledge that I had
临床课程的教学，基本上全是临床教学。然后在最后两年，即第三和第四年，我们加入法医队列，接受更多基于法医的教学。但我们在四年间的实习地点可以是纯临床的，比如在NHS心理健康社区或住院部，也可以是在法医环境中，比如法医心理健康服务、监狱或缓刑服务部门。这听起来太棒了，你所获得的知识和经验深度一定非常好。当我做助理时，我所有的助理岗位都在法医服务部门，我真的很喜欢我所拥有的那些知识，
to bring to the table and my experience of working in forensic services and and I really liked the yeah that knowledge that I had to bring to the table and my experience of working in forensic services and with you know forensic psychiatrists for example but I was aiming down the clinical route but it's kind of it's just kind of interesting and nice to know that there's there is a path where you could potentially combine both of them without having to do six years yeah and I guess what's really helpful is about this kind of doctorate is you have clinical psychologists who can work really in a range of settings because of their training so they can work in clinical settings but they can also work in forensic settings whereas from my understanding forensic psychologists are kind of more able to work just
以及我在法医服务部门工作的经验，还有与法医精神科医生共事的经历。但我当时的目标是临床方向。不过，知道有一条路径可以让你在不花六年时间的情况下结合两者，这真的很有趣。是的，我想这个博士课程最有帮助的一点是，临床心理学家因为受过培训，可以在各种环境中工作。他们可以在临床环境中工作，也可以在法医环境中工作。而据我所知，法医心理学家通常只能在
in forensic settings but I guess having this doctorate means that I can work in a variety of settings and really draw on kind of the skills from both disciplines so we know that in kind of in forensic settings or for example in prison population there's lots of individuals who are in there who have undiagnosed mental health needs or their mental health needs aren't often recognised or they're not often met in that setting but then we also know in clinical settings or in forensic mental health settings that things like risk assessment is really important on thinking about when an individual is well enough and ready enough to move on if they're in an inpatient setting into the community and think about what that means for not only public protection but any
法医环境中工作。但拥有这个博士学位意味着我可以在多种环境中工作，并真正汲取两个学科的技能。我们知道在法医环境中，例如在监狱人口中，有许多人患有未被诊断的心理健康需求，或者他们的心理健康需求往往未被识别，或者在那种环境中没有得到满足。但我们也知道，在临床环境或法医心理健康环境中，风险评估非常重要，需要考虑一个人何时足够健康、何时准备好从住院环境转移到社区，并考虑这对公共安全以及任何
potential victims of kind of crime so it's really helpful because you get training that's specific across all of those four years where you address both of those elements um because I guess I was kind of keen and either applying to my course or applying to the clinical course and kind of my plan was to keep rotating and rotating until I get into one of them and luckily I got into my course and I guess the only thing about the clinical course that I felt was that I would only really get I wouldn't get much forensic teaching and I guess the only forensic placement I'd have was would be maybe on my third year on more of a specialist placement um but I get that kind of throughout with my course at the moment which I'm really enjoying yeah so your placements
潜在的犯罪受害者意味着什么。这非常有帮助，因为你在那四年里接受了针对性的培训，涵盖了这两个要素。因为我当时在申请我的课程或临床课程时，我的计划是不断轮换，直到我进入其中一个。幸运的是，我进入了我的课程。我想临床课程唯一让我觉得不足的是，我不会获得太多的法医教学，而且我唯一的法医实习可能是在第三年的专业实习中。但我现在的课程全程都有这些内容，我非常享受。是的，所以你的实习
are well my question should be what sort of work are you doing on your placements and I don't you don't want to identify exactly where you are, but could you give us an overview or an example of what a typical placement might be for someone in your cohort? Yeah, so I guess the placements kind of vary. But in terms of the course, we kind of align with the clinical course in that aspect that you need to gain competencies and experiences working across the lifespan so that will include an adult placement an older adult placement a child and young person placement and also kind of in your neurotypical population so for example like a learning disabilities placement but also to get competencies in the forensic side you need to work with offenders and or kind of victims of crime and we know that in a lot of settings or a lot of cases that individuals who are victims of crime sometimes in later life then also go on to offend so I guess with that it kind of depends because I could be on a particular type of
我的问题应该是，你在实习中做些什么工作？我不想让你透露具体地点，但你能给我们概述一下，或者举个例子，说明你们队列中的人典型的实习是什么样的吗？是的，实习种类各不相同。但就课程而言，我们在获得跨生命周期的能力和经验方面与临床课程保持一致，包括成人实习、老年人实习、儿童和青少年实习，以及神经典型人群实习（例如学习障碍实习）。但为了获得法医方面的能力，你需要与罪犯和/或犯罪受害者一起工作。我们知道在许多情况下，犯罪受害者在晚年有时也会去犯罪。所以这取决于具体情况，因为我可能在某种类型的
placement and someone else on my cohort may not be on the same type of placement but we just have to gain competencies and all of that across the four years so my kind of how the structure of the course is is that in your first year you'll have a kind of 10 month long placement in your second year you'll have two kind of placements that are six months third year I think or fourth year it's kind of either one 10 months and then two six months and that could run concurrently so you have maybe two days in one service one day in another service um but it's I guess the course is really tailored to your journey so if you were able to get placement that it might be better to be there for 10 months then you might have a 10 month placement for kind of gaining specialty in that area so it does really
实习中，而我队列中的其他人可能不在同一个实习岗位。但我们必须在四年内获得所有这些能力。课程的结构是，第一年你会有一次10个月的实习，第二年会有两次6个月的实习，第三年或第四年可能是10个月加两次6个月，这可能是同时进行的，比如在两个服务部门各工作两天。但我认为课程是根据你的旅程量身定制的，如果你能获得一个实习机会，在那里待10个月可能更好，这样你就能在该领域获得专业能力。所以它确实
vary um so at the moment I've had a 10-month forensic adult placement when I was in inpatient settings and I've also had I'm currently on a forensic learning disability placement and then I'll go on to have another six-month placement at the end of kind of towards the next half of my second year if that makes sense it does make sense and it sounds yeah like just really yeah just very similar to the clinical it's just that you've got that added element of forensic stuff as well um and was your journey before you applied and was successful in this place was it already kind of quite forensic-y anyway because it has a little bit about what yeah what yeah what you did in terms of undergrad and you know
各不相同。目前，我进行了一次10个月的法医成人住院实习，目前正在进行法医学习障碍实习，之后在第二年下半年结束时，我还会进行另一次6个月的实习。这很有道理，听起来确实和临床非常相似，只是你多了法医方面的要素。在你申请并成功进入这个岗位之前，你的经历是否已经相当“法医化”了？能谈谈你的本科经历以及
where you went from there yeah of course so I came to my a-levels I got into an undergrad and I did my degree in psychology um and I had some forensic modules in my third year that I really really enjoyed and I had some health modules that I also really really enjoyed so I was kind of like oh do I apply I wanted I know I wanted to study further and do a master's and I thought oh do I apply for a health psychology based master's or a forensic psychology based master's and I ended up going with a forensic group so I then went and did my master's in forensic psychology and my attention at that time was to then apply for a forensic doctorate. And the master's that I was on was accredited for the stage one of qualification in forensic psychology. And it's kind of different from how it works. But stage two would mean you'd either go on and do a forensic psychology doctorate or you would be a trainee forensic psychology psychologist and get kind of your forensic placements.
从那里你去了哪里吗？当然。我完成了A-level考试，进入了本科，攻读了心理学学位。我在第三年选修了一些法医模块，我非常非常喜欢，我还选修了一些健康模块，我也非常喜欢。所以我当时在想，我是申请健康心理学硕士还是法医心理学硕士？最后我选择了法医方向。我攻读了法医心理学硕士学位，当时我的意图是申请法医博士。我读的硕士课程获得了法医心理学资格第一阶段的认证。这与临床培训的工作方式不同。第二阶段意味着你要么继续攻读法医心理学博士，要么成为法医心理学实习生并获得法医实习岗位。
And however long that might take, you would have to do a thesis and then you'd be qualified as a forensic psychologist so again quite difficult from quite different from um clinical training and a bit different from my course um after that I think I thought I would get an assistant post quite easily but I didn't because I didn't have a lot of experience I think a lot of people also experienced that so I worked as a trainee peer support worker for a few months I then moved on to a healthcare assistant role because I wanted to get some more forensic experience that was in a secure forensic unit I was there for about eight or nine months and then I got my first assistant psychology post and that was in a forensic service as well and then after that I was kind of at the point when I was deciding, oh, should I go down the forensic route or the clinical route?
无论需要多长时间，你都必须完成一篇论文，然后你才能获得法医心理学家的资格。所以这与临床培训非常不同，也与我的课程有点不同。在那之后，我想我应该很容易就能获得助理岗位，但并没有，因为我没有太多经验。我想很多人也有同样的经历。所以我做了几个月的实习同伴支持工作者，然后转到了医疗助理岗位，因为我想获得更多法医经验。那是在一个安全法医部门，我在那里工作了大约八九个月，然后我获得了第一个助理心理学家岗位，那也是在法医服务部门。在那之后，我正处于决定阶段：我是走法医路线还是临床路线？
Or kind of my course, which is the combined elements. And I thought maybe it'd be really helpful for me to step into more of a clinical post so I could kind of see how I liked it and see kind of what the differences were from my current position at the time. So I then went on to a clinical post where I was working across two services and I kind of found that I liked working in clinical settings but forensic was really where my passion was so after that I decided I would apply for the as I said the forensic clinical doctorate and the clinical doctorate because I could work in kind of either settings with both of those courses. I actually did apply for the forensic doctorate um I didn't get in I was on first reserve um and then I also applied for my course in the same year and I ended up getting on so
或者选择我的课程，即结合了两者要素的课程。我想如果我能进入一个临床岗位，看看我是否喜欢它，看看它与我当时的职位有什么不同，那可能会很有帮助。于是我进入了一个临床岗位，在两个服务部门工作。我发现我喜欢在临床环境中工作，但法医确实是我的热情所在。所以在那之后，我决定申请我刚才提到的法医临床博士课程和临床博士课程，因为这两个课程都能让我在这两种环境中工作。我确实申请了法医博士课程，但没被录取，我是第一候补。同年我也申请了我的课程，最后被录取了。所以
I guess compared to other people I don't have a lot of a lot of experience before I got onto training but more of it was forensic based. Is it a similarly competitive course to get on to as you'd find with clinical? How did you experience that? I would say it's kind of different in competitiveness because I would acknowledge it is still competitive and it is kind of hard to get on the course. But it's different in the sense where clinical courses, you have a lot more places. I'm not really sure how many places there are these days and it varies per course but you might have kind of 20 or 30 people per cohort and then you get kind of a really large number of people applying and it kind of narrows down with that but with my course I'm assuming that less people apply but also there's only five or six places so it is competitive but I think it's competitive in a different way if that makes sense. Yeah brilliant and in terms of the timeline obviously for clinical
相比其他人，我在进入培训前并没有太多经验，但大部分经验都是基于法医的。这个课程的竞争程度和临床课程一样吗？你的体验如何？我认为在竞争程度上有所不同。我承认它仍然具有竞争性，进入课程也很难。但不同之处在于，临床课程的名额要多得多。我不确定现在有多少名额，每个课程都不一样，但每届可能有20到30人，申请人数非常庞大。而我的课程，我假设申请人数较少，但名额也只有五到六个。所以它是有竞争力的，但我认为这种竞争方式不同。是的，太棒了。关于时间表，显然对于临床
we tend to expect applications to open around September and to shut kind of mid-November it is now and then applicate interviews will be kind of springtime how does it work in terms of your course sure yeah so the I think every year the application process opens in January and then I can't remember the specific closing date but it's around kind of May June or July and then your interview is kind of within a month or two so it's I guess the timelines are quite difficult quite different from the clinical course where they tend to be earlier in the year and I guess with the application what's different is as well as you'd apply through the University of Birmingham so there isn't like a kind of a clearinghouse portal that you would apply you just go directly through the university. Great and it starts in September does
我们通常预计申请在9月左右开放，11月中旬左右关闭。现在是这样，面试会在春季进行。你的课程时间表是如何运作的？好的，每年的申请流程在1月开放，我不记得具体的截止日期，但大约在5月、6月或7月左右。面试会在一两个月内进行。所以时间表与临床课程相当不同，临床课程通常在年初进行。申请的不同之处在于，你需要通过伯明翰大学申请，没有像临床课程那样的清算所（Clearing House）门户网站，你直接通过大学申请。太棒了，它是9月开始吗？
it is it academic year? Yeah so it starts in September and it's it'll be kind of September of the year you start till the September I guess four years after I guess the timelines could vary in that sense because if there were periods where for example if people are from maternity leave or they've got extended sickness then it's like kind of the minimum amount you would complete the courses in four years but if there are reasons that you might need to extend things then that is also possible the course are very supportive oh that's really good to know and actually this is ideal timing with this podcast going out in january as well because people might be like
是学年制吗？是的，9月开始，从你开始那一年的9月到四年后的9月。时间表在某种意义上可能会有所不同，因为如果有人休产假或长期病假，四年是完成课程的最短时间。但如果有原因需要延长，也是可能的，课程方非常支持。哦，这真的很高兴知道。而且这期播客在1月播出，时机非常理想，因为人们可能会想：
oh there's another little string to my bow and if people are waiting for clinical but they are in a position where they could self-fund or whether their current employer might consider self-funding them it kind of prompts a little conversation doesn't it to kind of yeah to not not even a backup plan but have a different plan you know something that I certainly wasn't aware of but this could have potentially been a quite a good route for me given my forensic background and I might quite like doing qualifying in both but it future proves you as well doesn't it so when I was um qualifying I was like well I could apply for forensic and you know I ended up going down into clinical places but you don't always necessarily want to work in forensic services
“哦，我还有另一条路可以走。”如果人们在等待临床课程，但他们处于可以自费的境地，或者他们的雇主可能会考虑资助他们，这会引发一些对话，不是吗？这甚至不是备选计划，而是一个不同的计划。你知道，我以前肯定不知道这一点，但考虑到我的法医背景，这对我来说可能是一条很好的途径，而且我可能很乐意同时获得两个资格。这也能让你在未来更有保障，不是吗？当我
and you don't always necessarily want to work in clinical services but when I became a mummy for me I felt like I wasn't so keen on going back to forensic and I know some people feel the same as well and when I was working with trainee forensic psychologists some of them were saying at the time you know I find it really difficult to work with people who've hurt animals for example and others would be saying well I find it really difficult to work with people who've hurt children you know there's there's different like hard limits isn't there but being yeah just being qualified across both areas is really nice future-proofing because you
获得资格时，我想我可以申请法医，最终我进入了临床岗位。但你并不总是想在法医服务部门工作，
don't know how your life might change or how you know society and culture might change as well yeah and I agree completely because I guess that's why I was really attracted to the course because I thought you know when I qualify if I want to work in a particular clinical setting and a few years later I might want something different than I have that flexibility to change and I've always said like I really enjoy working in forensic settings now but I'm not sure I would always want to work in a forensic setting and there are other areas within forensics and other areas within clinical psychology that I find really interesting like clinical kind of health services so having that kind of option there I think is something really important for me and I think that's why people might be attracted to the course as well definitely flexibility and choice like yeah all the way um something
也不总是想在临床服务部门工作。当我成为妈妈后，我觉得我不太想回到法医领域，我知道有些人也有同样的感觉。当我与法医心理学实习生共事时，有些人当时说：“我发现与伤害动物的人共事非常困难。”其他人则说：“我发现与伤害儿童的人共事非常困难。”你知道，每个人都有不同的底线。但能够获得两个领域的资格，在未来真的很好，因为你
has been really interesting to talk about with um some of the podcast guests recently is thinking about you know how faith and culture shows up for them and how that um fits with what they're doing in the psychology world. Would it be OK if you feel comfortable to talk about it, to talk a little bit about your faith and your culture and how that impacts on you and your psychology journey? Yeah, sure. So I am from kind of an Asian Indian background and I follow a religious faith as well.
不知道你的生活会如何改变，也不知道社会和文化会如何改变。是的，我完全同意。我想这就是我被这个课程吸引的原因，因为我想，当我获得资格后，如果我想在某个临床环境中工作，几年后我可能想要不同的东西，那么我就有灵活性去改变。我一直说，我现在非常喜欢在法医环境中工作，但我不敢肯定我永远想在法医环境中工作。法医领域和临床心理学领域还有其他我非常感兴趣的领域，比如临床健康服务。所以拥有这种选择权对我来说非常重要，我想这也是人们可能被这个课程吸引的原因。绝对是灵活性和选择，一直都是。
And I think kind of being in a field as a brown Asian woman, there's not always a lot of people who look like me um there might be a lot of service users that are from kind of minority backgrounds but actually there's not a lot of professionals that look like me and work with the same people that we do so I think having representation in the field is really really important um and it was only recently in somewhere I worked that I actually was able to work with people from a similar background of me and I just found it really really nice to have that view there and I guess something that the course are really kind of seeing as important as well is with race and culture and actually in my course we have race workshops so we have them I think three or
最近和一些播客嘉宾谈论的话题非常有趣，那就是思考信仰和文化如何影响他们，以及这如何与他们在心理学世界中所做的事情相契合。如果你觉得舒服的话，谈谈你的信仰和文化，以及它们如何影响你和你的心理学之旅，可以吗？当然可以。我来自亚洲印度背景，我也遵循一种宗教信仰。
four times a year and we get together with our cohort and some members of the course team and we talk about things like race and culture and what we bring to our training how we can help others to explore their race and culture and the impact that it has on them in their lives so I think that's something that's really important to think about um and yeah and just know because I think that's maybe not something that a lot of people know about the course that they are really driven about that and I guess the course is based in Birmingham and Birmingham is a really diverse area so thinking about working with the communities we serve and having that representation and developing kind of professionals and trainees who are
作为一名棕色皮肤的亚洲女性，在这个领域里，并不是总有很多长得像我的人。服务对象中可能有很多来自少数族裔背景的人，但实际上并没有很多长得像我、并与我们共事的人。所以我认为在领域内拥有代表性非常重要。最近在我工作的地方，我终于能够与背景相似的人一起工作，我发现有这种视角真的非常好。我想课程方也认为这一点非常重要，那就是种族和文化。实际上，在我的课程中，我们有种族研讨会，我想一年有三到
minded in that sense and they have an appreciation for the impact it can have on people and their background is really important. Yeah I worked in Birmingham for four years after I qualified and it's it's a real privilege to work with so many different cultures and backgrounds but it's also a real skill so in my in my working week I would often be working probably with maybe even as many as one in four um cases were using an interpreter um either because the child or the young person didn't speak English or their parents didn't and we needed to be able to kind of make sure everyone was understanding what we were doing and it's it's a real skill actually learning to work with different cultures and to trying to respect different cultures and values and um I used to try and make it my mission that I would learn at least how to say hello and goodbye and how are you and to people in their own language and I'd like have it all written down
四次。我们和队列成员以及课程团队的一些成员聚在一起，讨论种族和文化，我们为培训带来了什么，我们如何帮助他人探索他们的种族和文化，以及它对他们生活的影响。我认为思考这一点非常重要。而且，很多人可能不知道这个课程在这一点上非常有动力。我的课程位于伯明翰，伯明翰是一个非常多元化的地区，所以思考如何服务于我们所服务的社区，拥有这种代表性，并培养具有这种意识的专业人员和实习生，
in my diary on the right page and I'd have to flip to it and then like remind myself but it seemed to fall out of my head as soon as I stopped working with a client but yeah it's important to yeah to do our best to work with people um to involve them with the service but I think it is also a very unique skill that you build when you're working in really diverse areas yeah and I think that's really important because I guess developing services that are culturally competent is really helping to serve the people that we work with and if we think about in a lot of cases that we know that help-seeking behaviors are less likely to be displayed by people of minority backgrounds or people who have immigrated here
让他们理解这对人们及其背景可能产生的影响，是非常重要的。是的，我在获得资格后在伯明翰工作了四年，与这么多不同的文化和背景的人一起工作是一种真正的特权，但这也是一种真正的技能。在我的工作周里，我经常会遇到四分之一的案例需要使用口译员，要么是因为儿童或年轻人不会说英语，要么是他们的父母不会说，我们需要确保每个人都理解我们在做什么。学习与不同文化共事并尊重不同的文化和价值观，确实是一种真正的技能。我过去常把这作为我的使命，至少学会如何用他们的语言说你好、再见和你好吗，
or not necessarily born in this country um so i think working with that is really important and thinking about what we can do to help the people out there actually access the services and get the help that they need and thinking about what we can do as professionals to make them feel a bit more comfortable and if there's anything that we can put in place to make that more more likely to happen i think that's something that we should really be thinking about all the time I definitely agree I definitely agree um and another question that I often ask people on the podcast is what your top tips or the way that you help yourself to not burn out um on your way to becoming qualified so could you give us a little bit of a flavor about how you kind of sort your work-life balance out so that you're thriving not just surviving yeah of course and I
我会把这些都写在日记的右页上，我不得不翻看它，提醒自己。但一旦我停止与客户工作，它似乎就从我的脑海中消失了。但确实，尽我们所能与人们共事，让他们参与到服务中来是很重要的。但我认为，当你在非常多元化的地区工作时，这也是一种你所建立的非常独特的技能。是的，我认为这非常重要。因为开发具有文化胜任力的服务确实有助于服务我们所共事的人。如果我们考虑到在许多情况下，我们知道少数族裔背景的人或移民到这里的人，
think a lot of that is really important I think one thing that's really important with that is firstly boundaries and I was listening to another episode of your podcast earlier and that was mentioned and I thought yeah boundaries is really important so for me what I like to do is I try my best and I'm not always good at this and I think that's a very big learning curve for me is to kind of work within your work hours and not go over your working hours and make sure you're actually taking care of yourself in that way and I guess the way that the course is structured is that we have three days of placement, one university teaching day, which is face to face and also one study day. And I try my best to stay within those boundaries. So I'm only going to do my placement work on placement days. I'm going to do my other uni assignments or my thesis stuff on my study day.
或者不一定出生在这个国家的人，不太可能表现出寻求帮助的行为。所以我认为处理这个问题非常重要，思考我们能做些什么来帮助人们真正获得服务并得到他们需要的帮助，思考我们作为专业人士能做些什么让他们感到更舒适，以及我们是否可以采取任何措施来增加这种可能性，我认为这是我们应该一直思考的事情。我绝对同意。我经常在播客中问人们的另一个问题是，你在成为合格心理学家的过程中，有什么顶级技巧或方法可以帮助自己不精疲力竭？你能分享一下你是如何平衡工作和生活的，让你不仅是生存，而且是茁壮成长吗？当然，我认为这非常重要。我认为其中一点非常重要，首先是界限。我之前听了你播客的另一集，提到了这一点，我想：“是的，界限非常重要。”所以对我来说，我喜欢做的是，我尽我所能——我并不总是做得很好，我认为这对我是个很大的学习曲线——在工作时间内工作，不要超时，确保我以那种方式照顾好自己。课程的结构是，我们有三天实习，一天面对面的大学教学，还有一天学习日。我尽力保持在这些界限内。所以我只在实习日做实习工作。我会在学习日做其他大学作业或论文工作。
And then I'm going to focus just on university teaching and socialising with people in the class on kind of my university days and I guess one thing that I try to stick by the best as I can is not doing any work on the weekends that's kind of uni related or work related I say that I try my best um and especially like around now and it's like the more festive time where I want to be taking time off kind of placement and spending more time with friends and family that's I think that's my saving grace and the only time I try and do work on the weekends for example I've got an assignment coming up or something really important that I need to get finished by a particular deadline but I find if even if that means spending more time you know Monday to Friday doing a particular piece of work
然后我会在大学日专注于大学教学和与同学社交。我尽量坚持的一点是，周末不做任何与大学或工作相关的事情。我说我尽量……尤其是在现在这种节日期间，我想从实习中休息一下，花更多时间与朋友和家人在一起。我认为这是我的救命稻草。我唯一尝试在周末工作的时候，比如我有即将到来的作业或必须在特定截止日期前完成的重要事情。但我发现，即使这意味着周一到周五花更多时间做某项工作，
at least I have my weekend so I can rest and recover spend time with my loved ones go out and do things that are important to me I like exercising I have some fish that I take care of my pets so like lots of things like that and that kind of helps to take a break because you know people always say you have to go on have to get on training have to get on training but actually when you get onto training you I kind of had the impression like I knew training would be difficult and I think there are times where I found it a bit more difficult or I've had more of a steeper learning curve. And other times where I felt, OK, it's not, I guess what I've learned, it's not intense 100% of the time. There are bits of the course where actually I might need to knuckle down and do a bit more work.
至少我有周末可以休息和恢复，花时间陪伴我爱的人，出去做对我重要的事情。我喜欢锻炼，我养了一些鱼，照顾我的宠物，诸如此类的事情。这有助于休息，因为你知道人们总是说“你必须进入培训，你必须进入培训”，但实际上当你进入培训时，我当时的感觉是，我知道培训会很困难，而且我认为有些时候我发现它更困难，或者我有更陡峭的学习曲线。而在其他时候，我觉得：“好吧，它不是100%的时间都那么紧张。”课程中确实有一些部分，我可能需要埋头苦干，多做一点工作。
And I have less of a social life on the weekend. And there are other times where I'm feeling a bit more relaxed and I'm on top of things. So I guess boundaries. And I think time management was a real one because there were times where I'm like oh you know I've got work coming up but I'm gonna have a break and then I'm gonna have an extended break and then I'm not gonna do any work which is bad so I think for me learning how to manage that to not be someone who's working 24 7 but taking some time out to relax is how things like you can stop things like burnout and just being honest with yourself and realizing when you do need a break and I think also being honest to the course team so we have kind of monthly meetings with someone from the
周末我的社交生活会少一些。也有其他时候，我会感到更放松，一切尽在掌握。所以我猜是界限感的问题。我认为时间管理确实是一个大问题，因为有时我会想，哦，你知道，我有工作要做，但我打算休息一下，然后延长休息时间，最后什么工作都没做，这很糟糕。所以对我来说，学会如何管理时间，不让自己成为一个 24/7 全天候工作的人，而是抽出时间放松，是防止倦怠的方法。要对自己诚实，意识到什么时候确实需要休息。我认为还要对课程团队诚实，我们每个月会和课程团队的人开会，
course team and it's kind of a check-in on how things are going with the course how are things going academically but also how are things going with placement and then the last kind of most important question is how are you and actually that's your space to be really honest with yourself and with the course and let them know if there's anything that you're finding difficult or struggling with and they are really accommodating and they are very supportive so they're always kind of looking out for your best interests and I think that's one of the really big perks of the course is having that support from the course team. Good. Yeah, it does make all the difference when you're seen as a human. But, yeah, people find it strange when I say I really enjoyed my training and my cohort have reminded me that I didn't always enjoy it. You know, there was one particular experience which was quite challenging personally and professionally.
这算是一种检查，看看课程进展如何，学业进展如何，实习进展如何。最后一个也是最重要的问题是：你怎么样？这实际上是你对自己和课程团队坦诚的空间，让他们知道你是否遇到了困难或挣扎。他们非常包容，也非常支持，所以他们总是为你着想。我认为这是该课程的一大优势，即获得课程团队的支持。很好。是的，当你被视为一个活生生的人时，一切都会不同。但是，是的，当我说我真的很享受我的培训时，人们会觉得很奇怪，我的同学提醒我，我并不总是享受它。你知道，有一次特别的经历，在个人和职业层面都相当具有挑战性。
And it led to me being quite upset, you know, for probably a couple of weeks couple of weeks and they're like well don't forget that because that was still part of your experience but on the whole genuine genuinely and generally I really enjoyed it like I felt like excited I felt proud I felt like I was able to achieve and like I was doing good work and learning good stuff and having good relationships with my cohort and the people in my team so I did enjoy it and I felt like like you said it was tricky at times um and certainly it's not much fun when someone says oh do you want to come to the pub um and you go no because I've got an assignment to do um you know yeah it doesn't you know work doesn't always finish and end at like 5 p, you know, your clinical placement might do.
那次经历让我相当难过，大概持续了几个星期。他们说，别忘了那段经历，因为那仍然是你经历的一部分。但总的来说，我真的很享受这段过程。我感到兴奋，感到自豪，觉得我能够取得成就，在做有意义的工作，学习有用的东西，并与我的同学和团队成员建立了良好的关系。所以我确实很享受。就像你说的，有时确实很棘手。当然，当有人问你想不想去酒吧，而你因为有作业要做只能拒绝时，那确实没什么意思。你知道，工作并不总是在下午 5 点结束，临床实习可能也是如此。
We've rented placement in your case. But then you've got an assignment that, you know, that's due in next week. And so it is another added layer of demand. But it's well worth it. You know, I wouldn't be speaking to you now had I not done what I'd done and got to the end. So, yeah, but you should kind of you should be enjoy should be enjoyable at least at parts along your journey I think yeah and I agree and I go through those similar waves of kind of the imposter syndrome when you first start and I think the imposter syndrome comes out every time I start a new placement like oh what am I doing do I know my stuff and actually then I kind of relax and take back.
在你的案例中，我们租用了实习岗位。但你还有下周要交的作业。所以这又增加了一层需求。但这是非常值得的。你知道，如果我没有做我所做的一切并坚持到底，我现在就不会和你说话了。所以，是的，你的旅程至少在某些部分应该是令人愉快的。我同意，我也经历过类似的冒名顶替综合症，刚开始时会有，而且每次我开始新的实习时，这种感觉就会出现，比如：我到底在做什么？我真的懂吗？但实际上，后来我会放松下来，重新审视。
And I think about all the teaching that I've had at university and all the things I've learned on placement, all of the things that I'm bringing from me myself as a person, from my background, my culture, my experiences, my pre-qualification experiences, which has been the most important and valuable and thinking about what I bring and what I learn and putting those all together. And actually, really, I think, oh, you know, I'm okay. I know what I'm and what I learn and putting those all together and actually really I think oh no you know I'm okay I know what I'm doing there might be some times where I don't know but there are people around me who can support me whether that's people on the course like my my cohort who really really really really get along with or it could be people on the course team or it could be kind of friends and family and just knowing actually I'm okay and yes it's a process it's four years it might be a
我会回想在大学里学到的所有教学内容，在实习中学到的所有东西，以及我作为一个人，从我的背景、文化、经历、资格认证前的经历中带来的所有东西。这些是最重要和最有价值的。思考我带来了什么，学到了什么，并将它们结合在一起。实际上，我真的会想，哦，你知道，我没问题。我知道我在做什么。虽然有时我可能不知道，但我周围有人可以支持我，无论是课程中的人，比如我非常合得来的同学，还是课程团队的人，或者是朋友和家人。只要知道我没问题，是的，这是一个过程，四年时间可能是一个
long time longer than kind of clinical training but actually it's really worth it in the end and it's really rewarding to kind of be in a job where you can help people and I think that's kind of another key motivator for me definitely it's the biggest privilege people people I think you either you are a healthy type of person or you're not um but I just honestly, I think I've got the best job in the world. You might have the second best job in the world once you're qualified in dual modalities. But I just love it. I love what I do. And it's I just I consider it a real privilege. Aniga, have I not asked you something that you think I should have done? I don't think so. I think we're good.
很长的时间，比临床培训要长，但最终是非常值得的。能从事一份可以帮助他人的工作是非常有意义的，我认为这是我的另一个关键动力。这绝对是最大的特权。人们，我认为你要么是那种健康的人，要么不是。但我老实说，我认为我拥有世界上最好的工作。一旦你获得了双重模式的资格，你可能就拥有了世界上第二好的工作。但我就是喜欢它。我热爱我的工作。我把它视为一种真正的特权。Aniga，我有没有什么该问你却没问的问题？我想没有。我觉得我们聊得很好了。
Good. We've covered most things most things but honestly it's been the biggest privilege to have you on here and to to learn more about this pretty unique scheme to become dual qualified so thank you so much for accepting my invitation to talk about it and you've done an incredible job and I know people will find it really interesting thank you so much for having me and I hope um someone out there listening to this might have an insight into a course that they might have not heard of and I hope it helps someone and if people get on to training as a result of hearing about it we want to know about it don't we we want you know contact me let me know and I can get in contact with you and let you know because you know that's I love it when people say oh I didn't realize that I could do something else
很好。我们涵盖了大部分内容。但老实说，能邀请你来这里，了解更多关于这个成为双重资格认证的独特方案的信息，是我的荣幸。非常感谢你接受我的邀请来谈论它，你做得非常出色，我知道大家会觉得这非常有趣。非常感谢你的邀请，我希望听到这个节目的某个人能对他们可能从未听说过的课程有所了解，希望这能帮助到某人。如果人们因为听说这个而开始培训，我们想知道，不是吗？我们希望你联系我，让我知道，这样我就可以和你联系。因为你知道，当人们说‘哦，我没意识到我还可以做别的事情’时，我真的很喜欢
instead of an assistant post and actually because of reading your book or hearing your podcast I've now I've got this job that I wouldn't even thought to search for so it's really nice when we get to actually impact in a really positive way on people's lives from what we're doing so yeah if this is useful for you along the line then yeah we love your feedback we love to we love to know so thank you so much and wishing you all of the best with the rest of your training and with your with your doctoral thesis as well thank you so much wow how amazing was that Aniga has blown, actually. It's really good to know that there's this dual modality way of of qualifying. And it might be that there's other courses that are also offering this across the country as well.
而不是助理岗位。实际上，因为读了你的书或听了你的播客，我现在找到了这份我甚至没想过要搜索的工作。所以，当我们能通过我们所做的事情对人们的生活产生真正积极的影响时，这真的很棒。所以，如果这对你有帮助，我们很乐意收到你的反馈，我们很想知道。非常感谢，祝你在接下来的培训和博士论文中一切顺利。非常感谢。哇，太棒了。Aniga 真的让我大开眼界。很高兴知道还有这种双重模式的资格认证方式。全国可能还有其他课程也提供这种选择。
Or it might just be that it's still Birmingham that are the only people doing it. But how incredible to think that that exists. So thank you so much to Aniga. And like we said, if you find this interesting or if it leads you down a different path than the one that you'd imagined, let us know. Let me know how that pans out for you. Do come along and share your thoughts about this episode and any other episode in the Aspiring Psychologist community on Facebook. Come along. It will say brackets free group. And if you'd like some more bespoke support, advice, guidance, please do consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And recently, someone in the membership had said that they'd joined because they weren't feeling that supported or understood by their supervisor at the time. And actually, it really helped them to feel like they were able to gain more relevant skills and
或者可能只有伯明翰还在做这件事。但想到它的存在真是太不可思议了。所以非常感谢 Aniga。就像我们说的，如果你觉得这很有趣，或者它引导你走上了一条与你想象中不同的道路，请告诉我们。让我知道这对你有什么影响。欢迎加入 Facebook 上的 Aspiring Psychologist 社区，分享你对本集或任何其他剧集的想法。加入吧，它会显示括号里的‘免费群组’。如果你需要更多定制的支持、建议和指导，请考虑加入 Aspiring Psychologist 会员。最近，一位会员说他们加入是因为当时没有从主管那里得到足够的支持或理解。实际上，这确实帮助他们感觉自己能够获得更多相关的技能和
experience. And that has been something that had been invaluable for them. So maybe you are in a particular job situation where you're not feeling perhaps able to learn CBT or different specialist approaches, such as cognitive analytic therapy or, you're just not feeling able to do much reflective practice where you are working or with the staff team around you. And that's something that we really excel at in the membership as well. So if you think that might be useful, please do come along and consider joining us because it's a really nice supportive community. Thank you so much for listening. Please do take a moment to drop a review or even just a rating on Apple Podcasts because it helps us to prove that what we're doing is useful and so helps us reach a wider audience.
经验。这对他们来说是无价的。所以也许你正处于某种特定的工作环境中，感觉无法学习 CBT 或不同的专业方法，例如认知分析疗法，或者你只是觉得在工作的地方或与周围的员工团队一起无法进行太多的反思性实践。这也是我们在会员服务中非常擅长的。所以如果你认为这可能有用，请加入我们，考虑成为会员，因为这是一个非常友好和支持性的社区。非常感谢你的收听。请花点时间在 Apple Podcasts 上留下评论，甚至只是打个分，因为这有助于我们证明我们所做的事情是有用的，从而帮助我们接触到更广泛的受众。
Thank you so much for your time and as ever for being part of my world. Take care. So many tips and lessons to learn from So many things that you can try The Aspiring Psychologist Collective The Aspiring Psychologist Collective My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend
非常感谢你的时间，也一如既往地感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。有太多的技巧和经验可以学习，有太多的事情可以尝试。Aspiring Psychologist Collective，Aspiring Psychologist Collective。我叫 Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家。这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐
this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这本书，它会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。